hey guys today I'm going to show you our
electric setup this is my where my
battery bank is right and this is where
my inverter is I have my charge
controller there's also my charge
controller for the wind turbine believe
it or not the house the whole house is
plugged into here which is why I don't
like this very good product absolutely
excellent excellent product so far I
have not had any problems whatsoever
with this thing and it's been working
like a horse for this house and for all
of them like all the farm the whole farm
everything that has to do electricity
goes through this little bad boy so and
it's been more than enough for our needs
up to now but I do see that in a very
soon future we're gonna have to upgrade
this to a full sized system I'm already
kind of starting all right so hey go
that's our system and so subscribe put
your comments down bad or good
dealer bye